this is david rawlings he is a master of
swordsmanship and weapon arts with over
25 years experience and is the founder
of the london long sword academy today
he's looking at more of the weapons and
fighting styles from the intense melee
brawls of chivalry 2. so actually i tend
to think that a recorder could be a
really really really good weapon
provided it was made out of metal and
extremely extremely sturdy possibly
sharpened and possibly with an axe head
on it but it's amusing unless everybody
knows being in the same room as
as a recorder is murder
[Music]
i highly recommend checking out the
london longsword academy all the links
and information will be in the
description but without further ado
let's see what a swordmaster makes of
chivalry 2.
[Music]
this is not a creek messer but for our
argument this will work just as well
when you're looking at a sword it will
have a number of edges somewhere between
one
one and a bit and two in general now
with a long sword usually what you have
is two and they're the same length if
you have a messer or a krig messer or a
starter that factor changes and that
will be basically that you'll generally
have one long edge
then
one shortened edge and if you look here
this has what i would call a short edge
because it has a sharpened edge which
takes up a fraction of the blade not the
entirety and then you have a section
which is blunt that is really what
distinguishes it from the long sword in
usage is that this bit is blunt it won't
cut people the shortage might and will
act more like a claw in effect this with
the curve has this nice feeling being
almost like a cat's claw and it cuts you
in a slightly different way that gives
it more opacity of a thrust at the same
time yeah so also when we're looking at
messes obviously as you can see i have a
very very old tattoo here which is based
on the albion one of the album messes
and really what you have is
a weapon that varies in length varies in
size it has the same capacities really
as the sword of the same side of the
same size
would have so if we've got a really big
one it kind of works like a long sword
or even potentially a beaden bead and
hander if we have one that's short
sometimes they're choppy sometimes
they're incredibly nimble so they behave
very very much like a sword of the same
qualities generally with messes i i tend
to look at them as being the natural
extrapolation of a utilitarian piece of
kit so it's a piece of kit which you're
using in everyday life more of an
agricultural weapon because it's just
something that you have to do everything
whether i use it to cut wood i use it to
cut this i use it to cut food i use it
to do that now that might
mean that it needs to have different
pictures according to what you want it
for and i think when you get into the
idea of being a greek messer well what
do you want you messed up i wanted to go
to more win okay should we make it
bigger what do you think is it going to
be dealing with quite so many chickens
depends how you see your opposition
i like the maze in general because it
really it's um it takes away from the
need for discussion it's like what do
you do with it well basically all of the
things that you do with a single-handed
sword except that you know it's not
going to cut other than it's going to
split things open with the flanges so
yeah uses thrust with it smash them i
would like to see more leg hits i really
would more joy to be had with the weapon
i think but then yeah i do like that you
just smash things with it there's
there's not too much to say
[Applause]
so when we're talking about carrying in
games and rip costs and this kind of
thing simplest way of looking at it is
you can either be attacking or you can
be defending and that's going to be
really any of your parries you can be
doing a combination of attacking and
defending which is that you
carry something out of the way and in
the same motion of parrying you managed
to hit your opponent okay now obviously
the counter to that is really that you
do an attack which doesn't connect with
their weapon while you move but then
fundamentally you've moved and you're
just attacking so that's not really the
same thing the time that you do it in
might be the same so if we discuss indes
or something or really the idea of doing
something in the same tempo as their
opponent or at the same time as them
what that could mean is that if they hit
me
and i do something which pushes their
sword aside as their head comes in and i
stab them in the same time and motion
as their hit that would be a
simultaneous counter in effect when
we're looking at a parry it's really
just the prevention of our opponent
hitting us through any interaction of
our blade that prevents their blade from
hitting us and our past really is
something that comes out of that parry
in whichever way and kind of like has a
return time to it so it's an
interruption followed by another attack
so that would generally be the
terminology i'd use
i always wonder with these things as
well there's this tendency not so much
with this but there's this tendency to
run around with the with the hammer with
the blunt end forwards and i wonder how
much of the timing just reverse the
thing and just spike people just because
there's gonna be so much more little
gaps you can get that thing in so i
don't know which uh you'd need to hit
someone in the head and go like actually
this is much more uncomfortable if you
hit me with the hammer than the spike
this again i think we have very much
this mismatch this feels very much
something that should be being used on a
horse so the momentum can
have its maximum effect i think using
the horse as the momentum would be
useful for the heck for the axe on foot
i don't know there's something i'd like
to research more rather than actually
make a statement from
[Applause]
it's in these little single person
encounter or two-person encounters that
you can really see much more the flaws
or the differences that i would suggest
that you'd see in combat so quite often
in the paris it's just when you parry
and then there's another one comes
rather than you parry and the person's
weapon's here so you just shunt straight
in the face and i think that that's
something which is understandable given
the issues of latency and this kind of
thing but
again it's something that would be nice
to have as i said that if your weapon is
down here and you're not parrying
properly the next thing you're going to
get is going to be a shunt in the face
rather than just this blind whaling but
again this is more a critique of
one-on-one fights rather than when
there's mass twice
the leg survival target if your opponent
starts
basically doing something that brings
their hands back for obsesses with going
forwards there's always this possibility
to whip around and cut the legs or to
take the legs when it goes high
sometimes tactically you'll aim at the
legs in order to bring the hands down to
make hands more manageable so it might
be a faint of the legs or it might be an
opportunist opportunistic hit at the
legs so leg strikes very very
differently i think one of the things i
think people in in
sometimes don't pay enough attention to
is certainly something that's mentioned
when we talk about upper and lower
openings yes you can talk about the
front lower openings but the idea of
somebody coming up and then coming down
and attacking the legs and again it's
where its utility lies and if it lies in
pulling your opponent's hands down so
that you can interact with their blade
or manage their blade more efficiently
great if it's just because they've
opened up so much by excelling above
that you can go past and cut the legs
also great
[Applause]
[Music]
rapists can cut how exciting is that and
basically again this all comes down to
how you design the blade if you have a
cup hilt and it has quite a wide blade
on it that's got a flattened section to
it it's going to be somewhat better at
cutting than others if you want
something that's longer and more rigid
it's less likely to be good at cutting
than some others so all of these things
are trade-offs and they're not really
subject to the shape or the design of
the hilt you can have a design of hilt
that does very very um that works with
many different types of blade i like
what they've done with this
the main thing i would suggest is that
you probably want to maintain your
distance
against a lot more weapons than is shown
in these but again having played this i
know exactly what it's like one of the
things i've got to say that i really
like about chivalry is how effective the
idea of just getting close to your
opponent and then just as you would
expect to make contact you move back a
little bit so they fill in the gap and
they make a bad time so you can hit and
this is something which is so important
in benson is getting somebody to
misjudge when they make their attack so
this is something that you can use in
chivalry and seems to work very very
well whether we do it is probably
representative more of us as fencers and
players of chivalry rather than anything
else but it's nice to see its usage in
this maybe maybe a little bit more use
in extension but again it depends what
your opponent is doing so closing
sometimes is good
[Music]
[Applause]
so actually i tend to think that a
recorder could be a really really really
good weapon provided it was made out of
metal and extremely extremely sturdy
possibly sharpened and possibly with an
axe head on it but it's amusing unless
everybody knows being in the same room
as
a recorder is murder
[Music]
[Music]
so i don't know why the the pole weapon
play with this upsets me more
potentially than the sword and shield or
the long sword or the sphere hand or
beating hand as play does throughout the
rest of the game so in this context
seeing what weapon play which is just
basically hacking at people without
those little refinements of winding and
housing and all these kind of things i
don't mind it it's just hack and slash
and it's there when you get there it
would be nice to see things where you do
a thrust at someone's face and their
shield comes up and you cut their legs
but the difficulty of doing that in this
kind of game i think is prohibited there
are things that we could critique and
the recognition that if you're cutting
then you're going to get thrust this is
one thing chivalry does do very well is
the timing that if you're going to do a
cut when you get it wrong and someone
stabs you you get stabbed and that is
nice so then you have this need to
dominate this line and particularly with
the weapons with a greater lever a
longer lever it would be nice to see the
importance of the necessity to to
disconnect from the weapon the desire to
use the point to get through with like
jabbing motions on the hook to pull back
on the weapon in order to dominate quite
kind of a narrow line and then to
recognize that that narrow line if it
comes higher up one side exposes you
below i think all of the critiques which
in general if we were talking an
individual at a duel between two people
i would lose criticism of the long sword
and single-handed weapons in the poll
weapons i think is more so we should see
more of this subtlety and less of this
just like run up and go black unless
your opponents got back to you
one of the things to bear in mind with
pole arms of course is what little
attachments it has so if you look at it
as being like a little swiss army swiss
army knife each little piece of it has a
different use so obviously he's got a
hook what are you going to use the hook
for if it has a spike what's that going
to be for if it's got a little slot
between the hook and it has kind of a
bar that goes down the back and then
this separation between the beacon the
beak of the weapon and the blade of the
weapon was that going to be useful
probably for steering a weapon for a
brief amount of time so you can do
something else or potentially your mate
can do something else so the fascinating
things with pole arms for me
is that they have so much more utility
than things like the long sword the army
sword and the side saw the rapier
because they're being used for lots of
different things and some of the time
this is kind of incidental and i think
their progression from being a civilian
a civilian tool into being a weapon and
sometimes it's that every single bit has
been designed to do a certain job and i
think
getting to explore that is a wonderful
thing unfortunately that's never really
going to come across in a game like
sugary because you need to have a
different mechanic for each one of those
little things but potentially again the
hooking the thrusting these are things
that would be good to see
if you'd like to see more of david and
further sword-based shenanigans on the
channel make sure to like the video and
let us know in the comments and if you
want to see more of the london longsword
academy you can check out some of their
videos as well as all their links in the
description below thanks for watching
[Music]
you